El pulpo Odie nadó a casa con una velocidad constante.
Marcó la distancia que recorría cada 1/7
de segundo en la gráfica de abajo.
No todos los pulpos pueden crear gráficas,
pero bueno, Odie no es un pulpo común.
¿Cuál es la velocidad de Odie en m/s?
Es importante que hagamos la observación
que usamos m/s para mostrar las unidades
de metro por segundo, ok, lo representamos como m/s.
Y lo que aquí nos están pidiendo, es la
velocidad de Odie.
Nosotros vamos a calcular la velocidad como
la distancia que Odie está recorriendo...
distancia en metros, por la cantidad de tiempo
que mediremos en segundos.
Con eso tenemos m/s ¿ven?
Es esta medida que hemos utilizado aquí.
Entonces vamos a tomar un punto que esté
perfectamente marcado y de estos puntos que
fue graficando Odie, podemos hablar de este
punto, el cual está perfectamente ubicado
y podemos ver que en distancia recorrió,
4/7... vamos a escribirlos aquí...
4/7 de metro ha recorrido, ¿en qué tiempo?
vamos a checar dónde está el tiempo.
El tiempo nos los está indicando aquí,
el tiempo son 5/7...
5/7 y esto lo tenemos en segundos,
¿estamos de acuerdo?
Ok, una vez que tenemos esto, podemos pensar
entonces
que vamos a hacer la división de 4/7 entre 5/7.
Vamos a reescribirlo para que nos quede muy
claro, 4/7 será dividido entre 5/7,
de aquí tenemos los metros sobre segundos como lo
habíamos manejado anteriormente
y vamos a ponerlos ahora como m/s.
Entonces lo que vamos a hacer es esta división y para que nosotros podamos hacer una división de fracciones,
lo que haremos es multiplicar
los 4/7 que tenemos y la división la llevaremos
a cabo por la multiplicación de su recíproco,
es decir, 4/7 lo multiplicaremos a 7/5,
de hecho podemos ver aquí cómo se cancelan los 7,
ya que uno está como numerador y otro como denominador y tendremos entonces 4/5...
4/5 o de hecho, podemos irnos aquí arriba a nuestra
operación original y si cada uno de estos
los multiplicáramos por 7, se eliminaría
este 7 con este 7,
éste con éste y de cualquier manera tendríamos 4/5.
Y esa será nuestra respuesta correcta.
Hemos de colocar que son 4m/5s, es decir,
esta es la velocidad que Odie estaba utilizando,
4/5 metros por segundo.